on somehow I can imagine you were a
little bit of a rebel in school so I
mean chess players usually you know they
try to concentrate for a long time gives
you that idea yeah what on Earth gives
you that idea you know I I I did have my
moments of being a rather Naughty Boy at
times but um you know I did University
as well uh in the end but yeah yeah I
was ages ago now another part of my life
and they started they have started this
game number two must win for Christopher
you what's uh happening wow it's a must
win situation for white but Eric I see
is black he's happy with the draw and he
plays quite a provocative opening the
king's Indian defense and Christopher
you doesn't seize the center white could
have stepped forward in the center of
the board there and uh that would have
been the most aggressive approach
instead we've transposed into a
variation of the grundfeld defense and
here black is relatively solid I've seen
Eric icy adopt this setup before so he's
got some experience there and I have a
feeling he's got more experience than
Christopher you look at the clock times
already Christopher it's only 20 seconds
30 seconds down on the clock but that is
pretty significant because this is still
a very well known position white here
just needs to get his King to safety
that's the main move you just need to
play Fast Christopher save that time for
later you will need it does he have a
surprise up his sleeve I mean because
otherwise like you say he would have
castled already and the game would have
continued
I think he's just
I've never seen him play this before
Christopher earlier he had success by
playing very directly he was pushing his
King's Pawn on move one now it feels
like he's caught out in a variation that
he's uh maybe less experienced with it's
very very strange that he changed
opening because there you know if you're
winning if you've won every single game
with white why change you know it
doesn't make any sense you've won you
know two free games for white uh today
and you change your opening it does does
doesn't make sense to me stick with a
winning formula and uh this is now a lot
more positional uh this kind of
structure isn't it yes there's an
imbalance in the structure which gives
white still you know great chances but
it's not a full frontal King King attack
basically this kind of structure and
also what worries me is that uh this has
all been seen before you know he's
playing slowly and it's still pretty
much very thematic I mean I haven't seen
anything surprising and this is the
typical Pawn break that black does and
now the big thing is will white step
forward with a pawn in the center okay
like I remember key focal talked about
his position and he loves he loves
taking the pawn here and going for this
kind of ending but
um the only way probably to get an
advantage David you played his positions
a lot and they're great colors yeah what
would you do here I mean now I would
take the pawn but Christopher's last
move on the previous turn is known to be
inaccurate I mean if if you want to push
your Pawn forward and feeling keto the
white darts go Bishop you should have
done it a pre on the previous move
um now things are falling apart I think
White's stepping forward with the pawn
in the center is that mistake right big
mistake black is ready to open up his
dark squared Bishop look at Black start
Square Bishop so many Targets on this
diagonal instead we see a bunch of
exchanges the Queen's coming off but
Christopher needs to win it's not his
type of position every win we've seen so
far is imbalanced or him attacking
and especially with the Queens on so
right now black is absolutely fine very
healthy Pawn structure black has a three
versus two porn majority on the left
side on the queen side and actually that
tends to be a big factor in these
positions yeah I mean there's still play
left but as you say the Queens have come
off the board uh he's changed the nature
of the game compared to the other ones
and I'm just not sure why he was winning
keeping the Queens on the board so it is
strange
um or sacrificing his Queen is even yeah
you know he needs a screen give it up
um and black black has equalized her as
fair to say but it's so but it's only an
equal position yeah yeah look at the
clocks Christopher's clearly
uncomfortable he spent two minutes more
than Eric I see and also this is still a
relatively known position
um this will come with experience I
think there's decision making and
opening choices and things this this
Rook move looks rather passive I would
say you know he's just playing on the
defensive he's overprotecting his Bishop
I mean I fully expected him to actually
come forward with his pawns you know
there's a pawn imbalance in the position
I remember again just grandmastered this
this move here I was gonna I was gonna
suggest remember Grandmaster Keith Falco
is an expert in these positions he says
you've got to keep that pawn on the E
far where is to support your pieces you
don't want to move that pawn Force
that's his argument until it's ready and
actually white has now lost another
Tempo by not moving at Pawn forwards
he'd love to make some exchanges and do
what we call a minority attack on the
queen side using his two pawns trying to
Target Black's pawns but this is a long
way off now and black is just developing
extremely comfortably here yeah and
black has a variety of moves you can
bring your Rooks to the center try and
trade off a set of Rooks I would be
tempted at least to calculate pushing
Black's a pawn forward blacks three
pawns versus two pawns Advantage it
makes sense to play on that side of the
board that's where you have the majority
that's kind of classic uh chess wisdom
but look at Christopher you shaking his
head it's not his type of position that
is the key especially in Blitz you've
got to be comfortable whether it's
objectively good objectively bad it
doesn't really matter as long as you're
comfortable and happy to play quick
moves familiar with the patterns and
it's horrible to lose Tempo I mean this
move is a very typical way to try and
get initiative on the queen side and
again White's move there it gives up
some big squares the Black Knight can
now jump forwards which it couldn't do
before the black pawn can gain more
space and it just and here it goes the
pawn going forwards
black must be better now I would have
thought um everything's going Black's
way you are absolutely correct Simon
I am the bar
it needs a bar
and I like bars
and chocolate bars bars bars I was
thinking good night bars
karaoke bars yeah they're very popular
in there Norway aren't they so very
popular especially in the chess
Community
I've seen some videos
meanwhile a couple of Pawns have
disappeared from the board
black does have an isolated Pawn this
Pawn capture the black pawn that sits on
this C6 Square that's highlighted now is
a potential weakness but the problem is
black pieces are so good
this last move you know it's just
trading off more pieces yeah maybe he
felt he had to uh the dark Square Bishop
oh but hang on a minute look at this
move this move this is maybe a killer
this is just that pawn that black porn
which run all the way out the board
combined with that Bishop the two black
bishops they're just assassins they you
know I think this could be uh the end uh
it's sad for Christopher because he's
played such a good game today uh just in
general he's been really sharp but
a bad opening choice in the open uh in
this Bliss game I feel oh and now Arjun
didn't show any emotion I was getting
excited nope same face he's so calm he's
the new Iceman he is the Iceman
definitely he's got definitely no doubt
about it that dark sweat Bishop for
black it couldn't be captured because
then black would have created a very
strong path B Pawn one square away from
promotion this bishop can nearly never
be captured so you can either defend it
right now
you could also start calculating and
start wondering whether you can take
whites remaining Pawn on this left half
with your Bishop I would just defend
this with the Black Knight I feel yeah
um it's like full control reinforce that
bishop and uh that that white Pawn on A2
is just gonna fall has no Defenders you
can take that at Liberty
ah on the bright side he's caught up on
the clock now level two minutes just
over two minutes each
and he does take this Pawn Arjun is a
very quick very confident calculator but
maybe this is part of this kind of
negative thinking that you kind of
touched upon in the previous games where
Arjun just needs a draw so therefore
he's taking decisions that maybe aren't
the best well he wants to go for the win
Arjun here he's skewered the two white
Rooks so look at the black Bishop the
two white Rooks same diagonal
this is a check though where does the
black king go are there any safe squares
and let's remember you know black only
needs to draw uh to to win win the match
white must win
um but I don't know it's it it's got
It's messy to me I can't calculate this
position quickly enough I mean it to me
I'm not entirely sure what's happening
here now yeah um what is the bar saying
Simon I need that bar I reckon the bar
says equal that is absolutely correct oh
I am 0.0
oh hello that looks dangerous he goes
into the pin I mean I could never play a
move like that personally I'd be like
that is yeah it's beautiful though
because the whole idea the night moves
then the pawn takes the bishop yeah oh
hello no it does move but why didn't he
move his Bishop his Bishop's captured
now suddenly everything's falling apart
for white I don't understand I Regice he
showed some emotion I think Christopher
did he just blunder there I I think he
finally cracked under the pressure
everybody leaning back confident maybe
Christopher just forgot his Bishop was
on priest that's the first time I've
seen the Iceman chill yeah you know
properly chill he's lent back I think he
knows he's got this now yeah and uh
right now white is just the exchange
down a rook for night but
I promise one of those Rooks can move
you can pin this Knight the white
Knight's on the same line as it's Rook
uh it's also very tempting to bring one
black Rook down to the bottom of the
board eye up the white king
and the very best Christopher gets into
an end game with equal material but
unfortunately this pin
paralyzes his Knight and it's going to
be game over ardrin is going to progress
to the semi-finals he fought back
Christopher like you said it was equal
he should have just kept his dark score
bishop and crossed his fingers it was
still super complicated the same game
yeah Rook takes rook and well the best
white can hope for is just a draw yeah
that's not the best night you'll have
ever seen this white knight in the
corner struggling to escape yeah
yeah your exchange down here obviously
in the ending The Rook is much more
powerful in the night yes white has an
extra Pawn but that doesn't count
against such a strong rook and black
just has to be sensible don't do
anything silly and so centralizing his
King a little bit maybe try to exchange
the Bishops off let's make some more
exchanges uh don't blunder and you're
through as long as you don't make any
mistakes you know what I do here
[Applause]
yeah that's why
I know free draw no I just resigned
didn't say it will probably be accepted
the draw offer just because it would
help I can progress to the semis but a
draw is the same as the loss at this
point Checkmate now threatened actually
quite a crafty chat mate
um little net there the white King has
to step out of the check from The Rook
um but
I mean you really you I mean the white
Knight's actually dominated it's
actually look at that white knight
Black's Bishop is doing a great job of
just stopping it really coming out so in
the stable assignments he's in the
stable the horsey stable it jumps back
but it's just going to get captured in
every exchange every trade helps black
no chances now to win unless Eric icy
gets disconnected or Mouse slips yeah
yeah he won't blunder it's just not a
Regice style like it's actually
objectively a draw with best play uh
bishop and four versus rook and three
all on the same side of the board
but that is enough for everybody see
he's trying to repeat the position
what do you think do Miracles exist
um if he wins this one Christopher you
he's got to buy a lottery ticket because
I've never seen this side with the
bishop win this end game before night
maybe just needs a minute uh so close to
uh having a dream come true playing in
the semifinals with the top players in
the world
but he's already done so good being here
in the quarter finals
this will be the last time we talk about
him in a knockout phase absolutely I
mean he's 15 that's right 15 years old
and another just another Talent right
give him a couple of years it'd be uh
he'd be 100 points higher than he is now
crushing crushing more people so it's an
exciting time for the the American Jazz
Federation as well with Christopher
Mishra
it's Neiman yeah yeah a bunch of players
I mean there's actually dozens of
players that I only heard of in the last
year and suddenly they're 2500 Grand
Master Level and uh they're popping up
some serbians yeah yeah yeah lots
meanwhile okay the board is frozen does
that mean no moves Christopher you
just hard to create winning chances I
mean you're running out of material
can't create past Pawn four versus three
even if White had a rook instead of the
white Bishop it's still a draw so yeah
unfortunately no way forward he just
Waits
yeah there we go see looks very chilled
out now wow very calm
would you try to win that when this is
white uh I would play till move 100 just
for the fun of it and as soon as we meet
Rich move 100 off a drive
but yeah I mean in an over the board
game I think they would have shoken
shaken hands a long time ago yeah
why over the Border not uh online
there's more chance of a mouse slip or
disconnect or there's more variables uh
over the board
also I think
online you can kind of get away with
things over the board you just feel a
bit embarrassed if you play on in a
position like this where there's zero
chances of winning
well you can see Black's plan
maybe you know there's a chance because
era Garcia has like some pre-moves going
on
yeah kitty kitty play on that if there
was no increment for example the players
do gain three seconds after every move
if there was no increments play on try
and win on the clock
um hope for some pre-moves here you go
the king can't go to its beloved Square
so yeah if he does you can take the king
new rules
it's uh yeah it's still no way to make
progress even Bill Gates would win this
I can see in the chess 24 chat Bill
Gates who lost two Magnus and nine moves
nine moves now I'm not sure he'd win
this this is a drawn position
unless he's a expert Bill Gates you
never know be a real end game expert and
this one the pawns are disappearing
they're getting traded off yeah we're
about to see